le droit de vote des étrangers c'était
l'engagement numéro 52 françois hollande
du candidat françois hollande mais le
président aujourd'hui semble avoir
décidé d'abandonner à sept sa réforme le
projet de loi qui devait permettre aux
ressortissants non européens mais
résidant en france depuis au moins cinq
ans de participer aux scrutins locaux ne
figure pas dans la révision
constitutionnelle présenté mercredi en
conseil des ministres on va en parler
avec elle le mrap l'association
citoyenne qui a décidé de s'engager et
qui va monter un collectif notamment à
saint quentin en yvelines auparavant
vous avez la parole êtes vous pour ou
contre le droit de vote des étrangers
voici quelques réponses
je suis très partagé le sus tt j'ai pas
vraiment former mon avis mais je n'ai
pas assisté aux débats enfin le débat et
pas vraiment encore revient lancé je me
ferais une idée je dirais en fonction de
tous les arguments
pourquoi pas un futur ils payent les
impôts oui tout à fait il n'y a pas de
souci là-dessus je pense que s'ils font
partie de la communauté dont il ya pas
toucher à ce qu'ils votent
après au niveau national bon ben c'est
un petit peu autre chose je pense qu'il
faut réfléchir
parce que je trouve qu'ils ont leur mot
à dire dans une élection qui le concerne
aux municipales oui hein parce que je
pense qu'ils vivent dans une commune et
qu' il participe à la vie de la commune
et qu'ils ont le droit de donner leur
avis sur la main sur les décisions qui
sont prises pour la commune pour parler
donc de cette question du droit de vote
des étrangers sur ce plateau colette
parents bonsoir à vous et thérèse nouara
bonsoir également vous êtes
respectivement co présidente et
trésorière du mrap sur saint quentin en
yvelines
ce collectif qui a décidé de s'engager
puisque vous allez à présent à dès la
semaine prochaine à monter un collectif
justement pour le droit des
ressortissants non communautaires aux
élections comment ça va s'organiser
concrètement vous pouvez encore inverser
la tendance on voit que le président de
la république n'a plus envie finalement
d'aller vers ce droit de vote des
étrangers
oui on a vu hier que le président n'a
pas inscrit ce thème là à la révision
constitutionnelle alors c'était un
engagement de campagne alors que c'était
un engagement de campagne cela nous
contrarie vraiment beaucoup et nous rend
encore plus déterminés à
à nous mobiliser pour l'un
le respect de cet engagement de campagne
nous avons nous sommes inscrits dans une
campagne lancée par la ligue des droits
de l'homme enfin et c est signé par une
presse qu'une cinquantaine
d'organisations nationales nous sommes
inscrits dans cette initiative de
signatures de pétitions pour le droit de
vote des résidents étrangers non
communautaires puisque les communautés
en droit de vote et qui sont vous avez
mentionné on peut la signer en ligne via
un site internet qui existait à peu près
trente huit mille signatures
cet après midi c'était 38 mille
signatures qui avaient été collectés sur
ce site internet et vous vous allez
organiser un collectif aussi sur saint
quentin en yvelines la première réunion
aura lieu mardi à trappes
le rendez-vous s'afficher sur votre
écran c'est vous souhaitez y participer
vous appelez qui avoue rejoindre
aujourd'hui effectivement nous avons
demandé à plusieurs associations de
trappes et des environs de venir se
joindre à ce regroupement d'associations
ainsi que des partis politiques puisque
déjà je puisse dire que en 2005 nous
avions déjà commencé à faire un sondage
pour demander aux gens vous êtes pour ou
contre le vote des étrangers aux
élections municipales
nous avons eu quand même beaucoup de
réponses
oui bien sûr et à 93% je me souviens en
en 2008 nous avons recommencé une
votation citoyenne on envoie quelques
images d'ailleurs venu réaliser un
reportage à cette occasion de la
votation vous avez organisé notamment
2000 mètres
alors en 2008 2005-2008 donc avec
l'accord de monsieur le maire vous
semaine en main de trappes et nous
avions recueilli peut-être un peu moins
parce que en 2005 nous étions allés sur
le marché avec lorsqu'on va vers les
gens
c'est plus facile d'avoir des votants
disent on est là ben le pourcentage de
oui avait augmenté puisque c'était à 96%
alors ça c'est qu'on s'amuse a permis un
montage des sondages aussi au niveau
national convecteurs gagner très
récemment les sondages qui est donnée
par exemple c'était en septembre dernier
plus de 61% des français qui était
contre le droit de vote la situation a
changé ces dernières années
oui c'est certain qu'il ya quand même un
certain nombre de personnes qui sont
pour le droit de vote des étrangers ces
proportions serré c'est peut-être la
crise aussi économique qui fait ça il ya
un repli possible et ça dépend aussi où
est-ce qu'on fait le sondage celui ici à
trappes
il ya beaucoup de famille quand même qui
sont concernés donc vous voyez là il ya
des personnes quand même qui sont
émigrés depuis 40 ans et plus donc je
pense que les enfants et petits enfants
souhaiteraient que aussi bons qu'ils
aient le droit de vote enfin ils ont le
droit de vote parce qu'ils sont français
mais que leurs parents puissent voter
je pense que je ressens discrimination
reviennent sur le terrain qu'on peut
rencontrer ces différentes femmes contre
elle lui ressemble comme une injustice à
trappes
c'est une injustice et c'est une
véritable discrimination c'est pour ça
que le mrap est un peu en avant de là
dessus parce que si vous voulez pour
nous c'est très important de que les
gens puissent pouvoir au moins donner
leurs voix aux élections locales
ils sont ils votent des impôts ils ont
et ils ont des impôts à payer ils ont
ils sont souvent dans des associations
ils sont parents d'élèves ils sont un
petit peu partout et là ils ne peuvent
pas voter
le mrap le mouvement contre le racisme
et pour l'amitié entre les peuples je
l'avais pas préciser tout à l'heure pour
les initiales voilà les choses se sont
rétablis si le gouvernement a fait
marche arrière si le candidat hollande
devenu président a décidé de ne pas
l'inscrire dans la révision
constitutionnelle
c'est peut-être aussi parce qu'ils
n'arrivent pas à obtenir cette majorité
nécessaire des trois cinquièmes des
parlementaires
il faut que aller au delà de sa majorité
de gauche pour obtenir des soutiens et
permettre d'obtenir cette révision de la
constitution vous pensez qu'avec une
pétition ça va permettre de légiférer
peut-être différemment c'est à dire que
il est sans doute plus probable
d'obtenir des résultats aussi on agit et
si l'on fait quelque chose que si l'on
ne bouge pas ça c'est déjà clair et si
on sensibilise pas la population et et
les gens il faut savoir aussi que nous
avons nous situons entre notre action
comme vous dites dans le cadre de de
l'antiracisme que nous sommes aussi
sensible à la montée de phénomènes
racistes ça nous constatons ça un peu
tous les jours et que c'était c'est
vraiment le moment c'était au contraire
le moment de montrer que l'on considère
ses citoyens six travailleurs parce
qu'ils sont très souvent 3,6 et un signe
fort si ça se serait mis en place pour
lutter contre les discriminations lutter
contre le racisme de votre point de vue
oui tout à fait de notre point de vue il
s'est vécue comme une injustice quand on
voit que l'ailier les électeurs
communautaire de la communauté
européenne ont le droit de vote
là nous ne sommes pas sur la position de
demander le droit de vote pour toutes
les élections
nous sommes sur la position de demander
le droit de vote pour les élections
locales ont donc l'enfant que c'est un
sujet tout de même qui divise la
population vous nous disait tout à
l'heure ça dépend où on fait le sondage
ça c'est certain mais il ya tout de même
eu une division de la population peut
aussi peut-être comprendre que le
gouvernement après le sujet sur le
mariage pour tous par exemple n'ai pas
envie de créer de nouvelles divisions
nouvelles tensions ont écouté bon
peut-être mais là à ce moment là nous
nous souhaitons vraiment que l'on puisse
se déterminer quoi depuis le temps que
nous en parlons puisque bon je pense que
déjà en société dans les propositions et
priscille candidat mitterrand mitterrand
voilà c'est ça en 2001 et il a quand
même
si vous voulez depuis le traité de
maastricht qui a donné le droit de qui a
reconnu la citoyenneté de résidence
européenne mais a laissé de côté
complètement les extracommunautaires
et ça c'est pas très juste il vous
voulez parce que quelqu'un qui vient de
la communauté européenne peut voter
alors que quelqu'un qui a plus de 40 ans
dans la localité n'a pas ce droit donc
vous connaissez très bien cette pétition
rappelle c'est un terme à la racine et
vous allez la faire circuler aussi on
nous annonce voilà nous allons aussi
faire signer cette pétition sur le
marché samedi matin boxera intracom unis
bien sûr et puis à ce rendez vous un
collectif que vous que vous organisez
que vous montez le mardi 19 mars à 20
heures maison des familles à trappes
pour ceux qui souhaitent vous rejoindre
on aura l'occasion d'en reparler bien
sûr de suivre de ce dossier merci à
toutes les deux d'être venu au nom du du
mrap en parler du droit de vote des
étrangers alors que le gouvernement a
décidé de faire machine arrière sur
cette question cet engagement de
campagne c'est la fin du set 8 nouvelle
édition de demain vendredi avec katerine
the late haut ce qu'il faut retenir de
la semaine écoulée un point complet je
vous retrouverai lundi ciel nous
reviendrons notamment sur les réactions
de la communauté catholique à l'élection
du nouveau pape et puis l'essentiel du
sport aussi dès 18h30 en direct avec
anthony rech excellente soirée sûreté
des fils